my favorite movie genre is musical film
there is nothing like it i love musicals
i love the language of music and
movement that will always have a very
close place in my heart
i like historical films i like
dramatic films i like musicals i like
comedies screwball comedy because
the women are so clever and it feels
like the whole world is kind of orbiting
around these female characters
kids movies you know being a girl like
everything being hyper-sexualized gets
annoying after a while and i feel like
kids movies skip that i tend to really
like like drama with humor but really
grounded my favorite movie genre i would
have to say is a great psychological
thriller you know i like dark dramas too
i really like i love true crime
i love i love horror and anything horror
adjacent i like the films that engage in
emotional trauma most and then watch
people as they translate their lives and
overcome those traumas i'm moved by
those films more uh
ironically i'm famous for that [ __ ]
[Music]
you